hi I'm Leslie curry from the Yale School
of Public Health welcome back to our
series on qualitative research methods
this module addresses evaluating the
rigor of qualitative research to remind
us of the goal of this series we're
intending to enhance our capacity to
conceptualize design and conduct
qualitative research in the health
sciences there are six modules in this
series and this last module addresses
scientific rigor and qualitative
research so it's exciting to see that
qualitative research is increasingly
adopted in the Health Sciences
literature we're seeing grants be funded
we're seeing publications and
high-impact journals and so it's an
exciting time for qualitative research
in the world of health sciences and yet
there are some common criticisms that
qualitative studies face and important
to recognize those and to know that
there are techniques processes
principles that help mitigate some of
these limitations the first is the
qualitative research lacks
reproducibility so what is it in that
black box of qualitative data analysis
you know very different than taking a
structured data set for a quantitative
study and simply rerunning the code and
the statistical modeling which is
reproducible and it's absolutely true
that qualitative methods are not as
directly reproducible a second common
criticism is that it lacks
generalizability and we talked about
small sample sizes and qualitative
methods determined by the principle of
theoretical saturation so we're studying
and studying and studying until we hear
no new ideas from the data these however
are often small sample sizes and because
they're purposefully derived they're not
representative random samples we can't
generalize reliably to a larger
population
the last common criticism qualitative
research is that it lacked that there's
the potential for researcher bias all
over the place in the data collection
instruments that we design in the
process of interviewing and collecting
data in the field in the process of
analysis and interpretation and so these
are the worries of concerns of people as
they address or explore the rigor and
qualitative methods it's important as
qualitative researchers for us to
recognize and to be explicit about the
fact that there are a number of
standards the qualitative research has
long roots in a number of traditions but
even in the Health Sciences back to the
early 1990s in the BMJ a paper by Mazen
Pope which I consider really a seminal
piece in defining quality and
qualitative research and then many
papers since then from the NIH from
Kirsten maltreat in The Lancet from the
Jeon Khomeini and their group in the
JAMA so plenty of resources the korok
tool which is a checklist for
researchers as they report interview and
focus group studies so there are many
resources that describe the established
techniques that do assure rigor and that
should be used in order to address the
inherent limitations of qualitative
methods when researcher is reporting a
qualitative study we should be looking
for articles to include a whole host of
dimensions of the research and in this
series we've addressed many of these
first the relevance of the question and
the rationale for the approach and so
this gets to the issue of
conceptualizing a research study why
qualitative methods we need to be very
clear in the reporting in our articles
why it was we chose a qualitative
approach and within that why for
instance we're doing a focus group study
as opposed to an ethnographic
observational study and a qualitative
article should be very explicit about
about the rationale for the the defined
methodological a manuscript should also
be very clear on the sampling strategy
how were the key informants selected
what were the does
visions and decisional criteria for
selection in the development of a
purposeful sample what was the principle
of saturation how was that achieved and
very you know clear detail provided in
the methods section of the Train of the
manuscript in terms of data collection
we like to see the interview guides it's
very useful for reviewers and for
readers of an article to be able to see
what the instrument looked like the
interview guide itself and often we have
the opportunity to include these as
appendices and more and more online
journals for peer review of empirical
work are offering appendices we also
want to know about the depth of the data
and so for commentary within the
analysis section that addresses a number
of features of analysis the number of
coders who are on the team what their
training was was it a multidisciplinary
team what did the code structure look
like this is another product of the
research study that we like to see
submitted with manuscripts and included
in online appendices for the consumers
of the study to have a sense of how the
analysis project progressed we want to
understand systematic processes the use
of software were diverging cases
included what happened when there was
dis consuming evidence how was that
handled was there a process for
participant confirmation that
respondents validate the findings
themselves was there an audit trail this
is the process of documenting the
analytic process that I that I referred
to in a prior module so we want to be
looking for all of these aspects of the
methodology in published articles so to
remind us where where we've been this
series was designed to enhance our
capacity to conceptualize design and
conduct qualitative research in the
Health Sciences we've worked through six
modules defining what is qualitative
research spending a bit of time on
developing a qualitative research
question when is that when is there an
optimal opportunity to use qualitative
methods and just by way of another
example for instance I was part of a
team recently who was interested in
understanding the experience of young
women who have heart attacks and what is
the représente
of symptoms for those women and what is
their internal decision-making process
as they decide whether or not to engage
911 and so that study reported out in
depth individual interviews with 30
women who had had heart attacks and we
asked them to recount for us those
moments of the event and their internal
decision-making process a topic that
really is perfectly suited for a
qualitative design we talked about major
qualitative study designs in the health
sciences those are interviews and focus
groups we spent a little bit of time on
qualitative data analysis which is
complex and takes practice to learn how
to do but we reviewed some of those
principles and practices and then we've
closed with some notations about
scientific rigor and qualitative
research reminding ourselves and others
that there is a long tradition of
qualitative research and a number of
disciplines recently we see more and
more of this in the Health Sciences and
we can look back and should look back
and turn to the established
methodological iterator which offers a
number of principles and techniques in
order to ensure scientific rigor of this
methodology so I hope that you've
enjoyed this series and I appreciate you
spending time and so thank you and good
luck in your work